this is a production of Cornell
University hello my name is keny
Rodriguez I am a PhD student at Cornell
and today I'm with Steve reiners I'm a
Horticulture professor and the Statewide
vegetable specialist and today we want
to talk about harvesting winter squash
so Steve we have we are here in um
winter squash field and we want to ask
you when is the right time to harvest
the winter squash okay that's a great
question I'm just going to kneel down
over here and try to move some of these
leaves around so we can see this so this
is a blue hubard I think is what you you
said this it looks like a blue hubard
maybe a smaller variety of one so this
is called a winter squash as compared to
a summer squash and the reason why is
because these are going to take a longer
period of time to grow but they can be
stored through the winter um but the key
for keeping them long term is knowing
when to harvest these things like
zucchini summer squash cucumbers you can
pick them at any time and they'll be
fine when they're very small but with
these you want them to develop for a
full season because then they'll develop
a beautiful balance between sugars and
starches that you will get in this but
again the key is harvesting it at the
right time and a very simple way to do
it now here it is in August it's way too
early we know that um but as as you're
getting closer to the time sometime in
September you're wondering about when
you should Harvest an easy thing to do
is just what we call the fingernail test
and see if you can put your fingernail
into that and just done that very easily
uh because it's so very soft if this was
ready for Harvest I'd have a hard time
would almost hurt my finger trying to
put my my fingernail in there um so it's
again it's a very simple way to do it
but that'll tell you now you're seeing
this and if you look very closely you
can even see some water coming out and
but the nice thing about this if you
come out here in a week's time this
should actually have a callous on it
almost like we get scabs after we get uh
cut this will develop that same thing
while it's out here so again this is
something we would certainly be leaving
it's going to get bigger um but it's
certainly not ready for Harvest now and
let's say this was ready to harvest what
will you do next will you storage like
any other cuur beads or what will be the
procedure to kind of storage in the
right way and consume it later right so
if you if you have this in your garden
and you only have one or two of them you
could take that you could once it's
ready you could Harvest it you could use
it right away that would be okay but
again since this is a winter SAR that we
could store through the win if you have
several of them um what you could do is
is Harvest them always good to cut it so
you're getting leaving a couple of
inches an inch or two really of the stem
we don't want to pull it off that so cut
it using uh shears or or something like
that so you get a nice clean cut there
and then bring this squash into an area
where it's going to be 80 to 85° very
warm um and a high humidity of 80 to 85%
leave it there for 2 weeks 10 days and
and then what will happen at that time
is some of the moisture will start to
come out of the squash and that will
concentrate the sugars any scratches or
marks Nicks that you might have on that
will develop a callus so they'll store
better in that way as well um and the
the just the flavor profile will be
better once you use that so once you do
that for the 10 days to two weeks then
you can take this and put it into a cool
area not a refrigerator but something
like maybe 50 to 55° with a humidity
around 55 % or so so if you have a
basement this would be a perfect thing
to store in your basement um and if you
do everything right if you cure it well
store it you could have it throughout
the winter and even until next spring
The Only Exception with um curing would
be if you growing Acorn squashes for for
some for some reason acorns you don't
need to cure them and you you you can
just sort of put them right into into
the cooler storage we just learn about
winter squash and how to harvest it and
according to Steve we can storage these
but we need to have like certain
conditions and now we know when it's the
right time to harvest to thank you this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu